oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre de deux trois points d'abord
je rejoins complètement ce ce qu'a dit
Arnaud Bazin ce qui était vrai avec des
taux d'intérêt à 1 % sur 25 ans les plus
vrais aujourd'hui donc je pense que le
12 % n n'est plus d'actualité malgré
tout même à 12 % pourquoi exclure 12 %
du prêt du prêt à du prêt à tau zéro et
donc de l'accession à la propriété
deuxème point je pense que l'accession à
la propriété en Milie rural mérite bien
les 350 millions d'euros dont vous avez
parlé et je voudrais surtout insister il
faut faire très attention au messages
que l'on adresse aux territoires ruraux
c'est très important déjà dans les
territoires ruraux on le sait il y a un
sentiment parfois à tort peut-être mais
en tout cas il y a un sentiment un peu
d'abandon je pense qu'il faut pas
conforter cela et expliquer à un couple
de jeunes que parce qu'il veut
construire dans une petite commune
rurale il aura pas le droit au près àau
zéro mais que s'il allait construire
dans un milieu urbain il aurait prè au
droit il aurait droit au prè àau zéro je
pense que là on on on se trompe c'est un
mauvais message qu'on envoie et tout ça
génère des sentiments d'incompréhension
voire de révolte et on sait jusqu'où euh
ça peut aller donc je pense que sur ce
sujet-là et vous avez vu il y a des
interventions sur tous les bans du Sénat
je pense qu'il faut vraiment faire
évoluer la position du gouvernement
c'est c'est c'est très important pour un
enjeu financier qui est pas
extraordinaire